foreign
[Music]
people living in 365 square kilometers
which would mean that if Israel is gonna
go after uh leaders of the military wing
of the Islamic you had that is going to
definitely inflict a lot of damage on
the civilian infrastructure and kill
Palestinian civilians
Israel is going into its fifth election
in about two years as well for the past
two years has failed miserably to
establish a stable government because of
the frictions and divisions within the
Israeli Society we have a prime minister
in Israel who is serving an internal
prime minister for the first time in his
life and he is trying to maximize his
chances of getting more votes or getting
more cease for his party
[Music]
delicate position they are partners with
the history Jihad and their resistance
against the Israeli occupation and they
are also partners and what we call it
the joint Mutual command in the Gaza
Strip but in the meantime habas is
fearing that if they join the fighting
with Islamic Jihad against Israel Israel
will intensify its bombing against
Palestinian civilians and Palestinian
infrastructure and also headquarter of
security services in the Gaza Strip last
year Israel waged a war for about 11
days which inflicted massive destruction
on the civilian infrastructure so this
is the only concern that probably deters
Hamas from joining the fight against
Israel
[Music]
with our Hamas has the power to put an
end to the current fighting between
Islamic Jad and Israel I doubt that it
seems to me that Israel has gone too far
and Israel has good lines which would
make it hard for Hamas to convince the
Islamic Jihad to stop firing Rockets
against Israel I think it's gonna take
countries like Qatar or Egypt or the U.N
to try to intervene and mediate an
immediate ceasefire between the Islamic
Jihad and Israel
foreign